A malevolent spirit lurks
in the shadows of forests
and the darkest mountains
of the Philippines.
Capable of adopting
physical form,
the most terrifying a massive
half-human, half-horse hybrid,
the Filipino Tikbalang
thrives on chaos.
Capable of imitating any human
and cursing
the living with illness,
this creature's cruel,
high-pitched laugh
signals horror to come.
In most modern interpretations,
the Tikbalang is imagined
primarily with equine features,
but horses aren't native
to the Philippines.
So where do the origins
of this monster come from?
[adventurous music]
I'm Dr. Emily's Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
The Tikbalang is, at its core,
a malevolent spirit being.
While usually incorporeal,
it can take on
physical form as an old man,
monkey,
or horse hybrid creature.
While their shape may change,
their gender rarely does.
Tikbalangs are
traditionally male,
and their equine eyes, their
heads and legs mimic a horse,
with their arms and torsos
appearing human-like.
They're very tall
and very thin--
features made more distinct
by their ungainly see.
A Tikbalang is
like a Minotaur,
except instead of a bull's
head, it has a horse's head,
a humanoid body and
the horse's feet.
It is a creature that
you would encounter
at the crossroads
in the provinces.
So when you're going home
at night and you're all alone,
you will meet a Tikbalang.
That's Budjette Tan,
writer and co-creator of
the comic series "Trese,"
a series based on Filipino
folklore and mythology
that prominently features
Tikbalang characters.
I can't remember if it was
through stories that I heard
from relatives, or was it
a movie that I saw as a kid,
where Dolphy, a very popular
actor in the Philippines
who's known to be
the king of comedy,
appeared as a Tikbalang
in a movie called
"Once Upon a Time,"
where we saw Dolphy
transform into a Tikbalang
and there was even this
scene where he like carries
the two kids and they
jump over the moon.
I'm not even sure if
I'm remembering right,
but these are the images
that are stuck in my head
as far as seeing a Tikbalang
on screen is concerned.
(Dr. Zarka)
Existing in caves,
trees, and bamboo groves
deep in the forest, this
monster can imitate anyone
and can turn invisible
at will,
which it uses for one of
its favorite pastimes--
tricking and killing
local travelers.
Commonly, the Tikbalang
will lure someone off
their regular course
before keeping them
trapped and terrified
in the forest for days.
Take, for example, the legend
of "The Farmer's Son."
One day, a farmer's
son was hurrying home
after running an errand
at his uncle's house
when a stranger approached
him in the forest.
Although he tried to
ignore the mysterious man,
from the corner of his eye,
he saw that he was very,
very tall and very thin.
The two began a conversation
as the man kept in
stride with the boy,
his feet making a clumping
sound as they walked.
The man's long black hair
hung to his bare shoulders,
only partially covering
his extremely hairy neck,
and his eyes glowed
with blue fire,
contrasting with
the red glow of the cigar
in his large mouth.
The stranger coyly pulled
the boy deeper into the woods
and off his path.
Lost and frightened,
the boy allowed the man
to take his hand.
When the boy sat down to rest,
the stranger picked him up
and carried him further
into a dense bamboo forest.
The mysterious man
then laughed
a strange,
high-pitched chuckle
and abandoned the boy
alone in the dark.
The next morning,
his parents were frantic
that they could not
find their son.
After a long search, they
found the terrified boy
sick and delirious with fever.
Falling ill is a common
element of the legend.
It's said that to even catch
a glimpse of this creature
might cause illness,
a fever or a headache,
or even blindness.
Sudden death is also an even
unluckier consequence.
If a Tikbalang
calls out your name,
wishing illness upon you,
there is little hope for a cure.
It was five days before the
boy's fever finally broke
and he regained consciousness.
When he told his family
what he had seen,
his father concluded
the child had survived
an encounter with a Tikbalang.
His mother wisely warned him
to never go into the woods
with a stranger again.
Like much of the folklore
of the Philippines,
written accounts
of this story appeared
after Spanish colonizers
began to record
the practices and beliefs
of the Indigenous peoples.
Missionary priests wrote of
widespread fear of the monster,
a kind of ghost that can
appear as an animal or monster
and compel them
to do evil deeds.
But it's likely that the
oral legend of the Tikbalang
was altered when translated
and written down
by the Spanish colonizers.
The Tikbalang legend
likely evolved
as a blend of Filipino
traditions and foreign beliefs.
Filipino animism
practices largely revolve
around respect with
veneration paid to ancestors
and placation sought
from malevolent spirits.
A tricky invisible forest being
is well within
the realm of possibility.
"The Aswang Project" presents
an addition to this theory==
the early Hindu presence
in the Philippines.
Early religious
iconography of Hinduism
found in the Philippines
dating to the 9th
and 14th centuries
proves the religion
had a cultural presence
on the islands.
One of the avatars of
the prominent god Vishnu
appears with the horse head
on a human male body
ascribing the attributes
of speed and strength
to the deity,
characteristics that would be
adopted into existing ideas
of the Tikbalang spirit being.
Indigenous Filipino inhabitants
adapted components
like foreign language,
social practices, and religion
into their own existing
cultural beliefs.
So, while many
Indigenous people
seemed to willingly adopt
religions, like Christianity,
after the Spanish arrived,
many of their older
spiritual practices
were maintained in secret.
In 1613, Father Pedro
de San Buena Ventura
described the Tikbalang as
a giant foul-smelling ghost
or fantasma with wings
that kidnapped men and
weakened them until they died.
Increasingly, the Tikbalang
became seen as evil or demonic,
to use Christian terminology.
This paralleled
Spain's movement
towards a religious framework
that had a defined
system of good and evil,
a dichotomy made
gruesomely obvious
with the witchcraft trials of
the 16th and 17th centuries.
First introduced
by Muslim travelers
in the southern regions
of the Sulu Archipelago
and what is now known
as the Mindanao Island,
it's likely that
the horses of this region
came from trade
between Sultanates
during the 14th
and 15th centuries
and helped inspire the
Tikbalang's horse form.
With the arrival of the
Spanish Conquistadors in 1565,
the horse population
in the Philippines
grew and became sustainable.
Spanish colonialism
depended heavily on horses--
on the military advantage,
travel convenience
and perceived social status
equines provided.
The island location
of the Philippines
was a significant
traveling distance
from the Spanish supply lines
of the animals located
in Central America,
North America, and Europe,
so they turned to China
and Japan for horses.
By the beginning of
the 17th century,
horse trade
and breeding farms
were well established
in the area.
A lack of natural pasturage
and food supply
meant the horses
bred in the islands
were smaller than
their ancestors.
Continuing into
the 18th century
when missionaries uncovered
Indigenous
spiritual traditions,
they quickly labeled
the practicing individuals
as wizards who could
cause or cure illness
and who could change
themselves into animals
in order to kill others.
The more frequent references
to horses with Tikbalang lore
may have resulted
from these changes,
with Spanish text descriptions
increasingly accentuating
the hybridity of
the monster's appearance.
Today, this interpretation
of the Tikbalang lingers,
particularly in comics.
Arnold Arre's award-winning
"The Mythology Class"
first published in 1999,
was really
the first introduction
of the Tikbalang to
modern popular culture.
Extremely muscular
and tattooed,
Arre's version
appears more in line
with what readers
had come to expect
in traditional
superhero comics.
Their portrayal changed
when they started to
appear in pop culture.
That's when the
creators of their times,
whether it was the '80s, '90s,
or comic-book creators today
have started to take liberties
on how to portray
the Tikbalang.
It's one of those creatures
that has become
pretty much open
to interpretation as far
as what is the best way
they serve the story.
(Dr. Zarka)
In the world of "Trese,"
the creatures are also
incredibly strong and muscular.
Instead of shape shifting, they
can produce a magical glamor
that allows them to
appear as regular humans.
Now a popular Netflix series,
the animated portrayal
of the Tikbalang
reinforces the muscular
horse hybrid appearance
to an even wider
global audience.
These are our stories,
and if we don't retell them,
they will soon be forgotten.
I think we need to keep
retelling these stories
and find new ways to tell them,
tell them in our own ways.
It's not because we want this
to be the definitive storyline
of what the Tikbalang is,
but again, it's what
sparks the imagination.
It's what strikes fear.
And hopefully, this will
inspire the reader or viewer
to want to know more.
(Dr. Zarka)
Whether it's the terrifying
and gangly version
of Tikbalang
from tales told
in the Philippines
centuries ago,
or the ripped
and tatted incarnation
that we see on Netflix today,
one thing is certain:
The legend is likely to endure
for many years to come.
Sulu Archipelago.
The Sulu Archipelago.
Archip-eh-lago!
Archi-pelago.
Archi-pel-ago.
Sulu Archipelago. [laughs]
Of the Sulu Archi-pelay-go.
I think we just need to be done.